Pulsar just released what feels like
their billionth iteration of the X2
gaming mouse but this time things are a
little different the X2 aim trainer pack
comes loaded with basically everything
you'd ever need if you're an FPS gamer
skates grips and even some software but
will it actually help you click heads on
valorent let's find it
[Applause]
alright so a few months back I reviewed
pulsar's X2 gaming mouse it's a
lightweight symmetrical wireless mouse
with a pretty reasonable price tag and I
enjoyed testing it out since then Pulsar
has released plenty of different
iterations of the X2 mostly in different
colors but their newest release is a bit
more unique also I was kind enough to
send me their X2 aim trainer pack a few
weeks ago it's an exclusive bundle made
in collaboration with corepads and
Kovacs it comes with two different types
of corepad skates some grips and a steam
code for Kovacs if you have no idea what
Kovacs is it's basically just another
aim trainer similar to aimlabs unlike
aimlabs Kovacs isn't normally free but a
lot of cracked Gamers credit it for
helping develop their aim eventually you
know I downloaded Kovacs I you know they
spent like 20 hours on it like total and
that like it's significantly just like
upgraded my gameplay like from like
being bad not knowing what to do the
lady just like I feel like I was like
actually doing something I've been using
the X2 aim trainer pack for the past few
weeks with Kovacs and of course valorent
and here's what I think about the mouse
and just a reminder that this video is
not sponsored we're just trying to bring
you some more reviews on gaming products
that you might like I started off by
using the mouse the way that it comes
out of the box with the stock skates and
nothing else it felt nearly identical to
the normal X2 but the aim trainer
version uses swano blue shell pink dot
switches which feel a bit lighter and
nicer than the KL 8.0 switches on the
original I used this aim trainer edition
of pulsar's es2 mouse pad and loaded up
Kovacs for the first time it's basically
just aim Labs but with blocks instead of
Spears to shoot at you can practice all
of the same things like tracking and
flicking and download playlists from
other creators or build your own Maps
I've always wondered whether Kovacs is
actually better because it usually costs
about ten dollars on Steam well aimlabs
is free but I think they both offer a
pretty similar experience aim training
is something that has helped me improve
at valorent since it came out and I know
some people don't think it's necessary
but I do think it's cool that Pulsar has
partnered with Kovacs for this bundle
that being said I was honestly more
interested in their collab with core
pads I've used corepad Pros on my super
light for a while now and I love them
but I decided to put on this slightly
faster set of corepad air skates as well
as these core pack grips as someone
whose hands often gets sweaty while
playing the grips definitely helped they
don't offer quite as much grip as the
Pulsar super grip tape that I've been
using on my vaccine but they definitely
look way cooler so at least there's that
when I hopped on Valerian I was able to
perform just as well as I did with the
original X2 but I was disappointed when
my mouse two button double clicked a few
times during my first week of testing it
only happened two or three times and
unfortunately I only managed to capture
it happening once but it hasn't happened
since then I know some users had double
clicking issues with the original X2
switches but this is the first time that
a pulsar Mouse has done this to me it
hasn't happened since then so I'm not
100 sure what was causing it but overall
gaming with this mouse has been a lot of
fun it's the same safe shape that
supports a variety of grip Styles and if
you're an FPS gamer then I think you'll
be happy with it but the best part to me
is just how many accessories it comes
with a lot of mice nowadays ship with
extra skates and grips but not many are
as high quality as what you get with the
X2 aim trainer pack and the crazy thing
is that this bundle costs the same
amount as a normal X2 at only 95 US
Dollars Pulsar only released 1500 units
of both the medium and the mini but I
think if you can get your hands on one
then it's a pretty sweet deal it's kind
of like the perfect FPS starter pack
Pulsar also just dropped an X2 super
clear Edition which has all of the same
internals so if you're into that Retro
Gaming look then it's also a great
option and with Logitech still dragging
their feet and baiting us I think I'll
continue using some of my x2s over my
super light which just has outdated
Hardware but if you're like me then I'm
still waiting for an x-lite V3
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock